Are we going to war because Donald Trump is
sending troops to Saudi Arabia.
This is a story we've been following and in
fact, we've been following, there are sort
of like three stories at least that relate
to this, and I'll tell you what they are in
a moment.
But stunningly, there has been an extremely
small amount of coverage of this from corporate
media.
This is a major, major story and intertwined.
Our number one, the story of Donald Trump
claiming, remember he said he was the guy
who wasn't going to start wars.
Hillary would start wars and then as soon
as he became president, even military action
against Venezuela was suddenly on the table
among other countries.
So that story number one, story number two
is Trump as the subservient military industrial
complex tool in the context of Saudi Arabia.
Story number three is the implicit support,
or at least indifference to Saudi Arabia.
Arabia's devastatingly disgusting war on Yemen,
and we recently had sort of added onto this
the forced resignation of a national security
advisor, John Bolton, combined with some Saudi
facilities being attacked, and the question
that we had last week was, what is Donald
Trump going to do?
He tweeted, he would do whatever Saudi Arabia
wants, but what is he actually going to do?
Well, we've now learned that Donald Trump
has approved sending troops to Saudi Arabia.
Of course, in the context of blaming Iran
for the attacks against Saudi facilities,
which may be true.
Iran has so far denied it.
It may have, maybe Iran.
We don't really know at this point in time.
The Pentagon says, we're talking about not
multiple thousands of troops, although they're
not saying exactly the number.
That could mean several hundred that could
mean a couple thousand maybe we don't know.
And we're told that the presence of these
troops in Saudi Arabia is going to be primarily
defensive, which of course we've heard before.
There's also a plan to expedite delivery of
military equipment to Saudi Arabia and to
the United Arab Emirates.
Fast tracking the growing military industrial
complex under Trump, visa vi Saudi Arabia,
which we've talked about many, many times.
Big Arms deals.
Trump loves them.
We've talked about it before.
They are also considering a quote indefinite
aircraft carrier deployment to the region.
Now indefinite is definitely a word that we've
grown accustomed to since nine 11 when it
comes to military engagements and Donald Trump
ultimately is just going to do whatever Saudi
Arabia wants.
Just like he tweeted that he would last week
us defense secretary Mark Esper saying in
response to the kingdom's request, the president
has approved the deployment of US forces which
will be defensive in nature and primarily
focused on air and missile defense.
Mark Esper is confirming that Donald Trump
is doing what Saudi Arabia asks and why wouldn't
he?
Trump tweeted that he would do that last week.
Remember this, when Trump tweeted, quote,
Saudi Arabia, oil supply was attacked.
There is reason to believe we know the culprit
are locked and loaded depending on verification,
but are waiting to hear from the kingdom as
to who they believe was the cause of this
attack and under what terms we would proceed.
Trump said he would do whatever Saudi Arabia
wants.
And Mark Esper is confirming that Donald Trump
is doing what Saudi Arabia wants.
Now there are two interpretations of Donald
Trump's a deployment of troops and possibly
of an aircraft carrier.
One is an interpretation sort of of relief
because Donald Trump is merely setting up
some defense around Saudi Arabia in and around
Saudi Arabia rather than ordering immediate
retaliatory attacks against Iran.
That would be the most benign interpretation
of this.
The other interpretation is that this is just
pushing the door open with troops and an aircraft
carrier to further instigate Iran so that
at some point in the future may be timed.
Conveniently with the upcoming election of
2020, Donald Trump can use it as an opportunity
to really start a proper war up potentially
to the benefit of his reelection campaign.
At least if history serves us in figuring
out, uh, the, the cost benefit of military
engagements during reelection, it actually
tends to be a pretty good thing for presidents
seeking reelection.
Now remember that we were told that Hillary
Clinton was going to go to war with everybody,
but Donald Trump wasn't.
Trump wouldn't even consider ridiculous military
engagements like Hillary supposedly was going
to the Trumpist said it, Trump said it.
And in reality, we've seen Donald Trump threatened
military action against North Korea, against
Venezuela, against Iran, against Syria.
I can't even remember the entire list at this
point.
And of course in the background or questions
about Trump's relationships with different
countries and how they influence foreign policy,
Saudi Arabia, there are questions there, Russia
in relation to Syria and Venezuela and there
are others.
So the number of disgusting elements to this
story is large and corporate media is barely
interested.
And there is Donald Trump's implicit support
of the Saudi Arabian humanitarian crisis war
on Yemen, arguably impeachable support.
We've talked about that before.
That's never in the news, even though it's
extraordinarily disgusting.
There's the sickening military defense of
Saudi Arabia going on right now, despite Trump
previously saying that Saudi Arabia has to
take care of itself when Obama was president,
of course.
And then you have the continued military industrial
complex sale of weapons to Saudi Arabia, even
in the context of murdered journalists.
Shamal Jamal Khashoggi, who Donald Trump,
uh, who's murdered Donald Trump has done very,
very little about, could this be more backwards?
And in the end, this is just more confirmation
that Donald Trump, when it comes right down
to it, has no actual political philosophy.
He has no underlying moral code that informs
his behavior.
War is bad.
He says, if he can say Hillary would get us
into wars, but he can keep us out.
War is bad.
If George W. Bush went into Iraq and Trump
can now say it was a bad idea all along, even
though at the time he called into the Howard
stern show and says he would have done the
same thing or war is bad except if it will
potentially help his reelection campaign or
make them look strong in his own eyes or distract
from his crimes and grift and self enrichment
through the presidency in the end.
I don't know right now whether this is the
lead up to war with Iran, but it's particularly
disgusting beyond just like the general militarism
that we're seeing in a, as, as a feature,
uh, of what Donald Trump is open to because
it's number one all in the defense of a country
that we should be reducing ties to in the
first place.
And number two, coming at the expense as usual.
Just again with Trump, these decisions and
this infrastructure is coming at the exchange,
at the cost of our own sovereignty.
We are exporting more and more of the decisions
we make with our military and with our diplomacy
to other countries.
And that's extraordinarily concerning.
And barely a peep about it from corporate
media.